you know when what year did you get
Entourage you started in the second
season of Entourage right end of the
second yeah
um what what did you what was your uh
what was it like being on set working
with all those guys it was a lot of
testosterone a lot of things a lot of
things going on there's not many girls I
mean there are girls but I guess there
were a lot of women on that show right
there were but my world was very with
the boys did you like being with the
boys I've always loved being with the
boys apparently I'm great with moving
with the boys I don't know why that is
but if you like look in my career I'm
often times the only girl with
boys why is that I think because I had
an amazing relationship with my dad and
my brother and I felt very comfortable
around men they could say anything you
don't get offended no and also too you
know I always laugh I kind of joke about
this my boyfriend always laughs at this
I think that
I mean in some ways this is funny in
other ways this is really sad but I've
I've become super
I'm really good at flipping it
hahaha you really get what flipping it
like I can flip a situation like I can
flip an uncomfortable situation and not
make anybody uncomfortable it doesn't
need to be weird for you won't be weird
for me you don't allow yourself to feel
uncomfortable
I
yeah well it's not worth it
I mean unless someone really makes you
want somebody like you went over the
line have you had that
rarely rarely I mean I've had it yes
um on the work yep in the work place
um and I handled it
and there was very little backlash
and uh yeah I flipped it
I mean you ask any woman I'm sure
they're gonna say I've worked with a few
pigs in my life
right yeah
have you worked with some horrific
people before
no no most of them you can tolerate
and what was your experience on
Entourage did you did you really enjoy
doing the show the best what was so fun
about it 10 out of 10. 10 out of 10.
like an 11 out of ten you remind me like
almost East Coast I mean you are really
yeah you do you're very East Coast yeah
you seem like you're from New York yeah
that people told you that of my whole
life yeah you just seemed like you're
from Long Island like oh yeah shrieky
she lived next to the pellegrinos over
on uh with an ocean side where I don't
have a [ __ ] what was it
where did my grandparents live I forgot
yeah but that's how
the pillows so their name was cheap
Pellegrino she lived across the street
from my grandmother Ruth Ruth Eckstein
the pellegrinos lived across the street
Anthony uh yeah they all I walked over
you right yeah you right yeah so you
write screenplays but you need to use
that chicky Pellegrino